in the trailer for glass there are a few
scenes that never showed up in the movie
if you want to see which ones then stick
around to the end of this video hi my
name is cz and I created a series called
things you missed where I analyze horror
movies based on some of the things that
you might have missed it's pretty
self-explanatory as a result of making
these episodes I end up scrubbing
through the trailers a lot to find
footage so I ended up noticing that
there were quite a few scenes in the
trailers that weren't actually in the
movie I decided to look it up and see
what info I could find on this cut
content and ended up stumbling on an
interview titled M night Shyamalan
reveals why his first cut of glass was 3
hours and 20 minutes that's crazy to me
I mean to give you a better idea the
final runtime was 2 hours and 9 minutes
so over an hour of content was cut not
all of that is gonna be deleted scenes
some of it is probably just tightening
up existing scenes and removing a few of
the 24 identities of the Horde but still
that's a lot of footage left on the
cutting-room recycle bin here's what
Shyamalan had to say in the interview
tons of deleted scenes I think in
retrospect the firt this was the first
time I was writing characters that I
already knew so I could write a lot and
that's not normal normally I'm finding
them as I'm writing and the editing
process was what is the most and the
essence of what I needed so there's a
lot of deleted scenes for the blu-ray
with this being our last look into the
universe the deleted scenes do kind of
interest me just to get one last look at
these characters we've grown to love but
the blu-ray won't be out until April so
that leaves us with these scenes better
in the trailers let's take a look at
them
this is the first one and David sitting
in this restaurant this woman asked him
what he does and he tells her that he's
in security there's also a slot machine
in the corner and the TV is broadcasting
the opening of osaka tower i'd theorized
that this was meant to be the opening
scene it picks up where david left off
and split alone in a diner not literally
the same diner but symbolically picking
up where we left off and why was it cuts
if you've seen unbreakable and you
already know who David is and we find
out about what happened to his wife in
another scene so showing him alone again
would really just be redundant next
we've got this scene of David in his
rain poncho throwing someone up on a
wall it looks like he's in some sort of
tunnel and
from what I can tell he's protecting a
woman who's been attacked by this
criminal I think this is a purse right
over here and this probably takes place
before the face-off with the Beast at
the factory and again we already get a
good idea of David's life of vigilante
justice in this other scene this scene
may not have been needed I do like the
symbolic shot composition though with
the wall colors being yellow and purple
the colors of the hoard and mr. glass
and this fence in the foreground telling
us that David is gonna be locked in with
these two enemies in fact it even has
the same pattern as the window on the
door - mr. glasses room this next one
takes place in the final battle sequence
it would seem that there's a moment
where Joseph's wrist is injured at some
point and it looks like this might be
after Casey goes to try to get Kevin to
come into the light because she's not
there on the steps with them so there
may have been a beat where the Beast
hurts Joseph I also wouldn't be
surprised if the black clover society
was responsible and I have to wonder if
part of that hour of cut content was
Joseph's questioning if the superpowers
were somehow hereditary no not that
hereditary and he tries to do something
that only his father would have been
able to do perhaps the most mysterious
of the deleted scenes though is this
where the Beast is clutching this
woman's head it doesn't appear to be in
a violent way though that my first
thought was that this was dr. staple but
the outfit doesn't seem to match what
she was wearing after mr. glass broke
the horde out of his room my theory is
that there was a scene where they run
into another patient at the institution
and the Beast for the same reasons that
he let Casey go at the end of split lets
her go because he sees that she is
broken and therefore pure we also get a
better look at this during the final
trailer and we see that there are many
people possibly patients of Ravenhill
that are reaching out to beast in some
kind of therapeutic ritual
there's nothing similar to that in the
movie so I'd be interested to
potentially find out what was going on
there let me know what your theories are
about what was left out of the movie and
anything you may have noticed from the
trailers that didn't make the cut
I'll also be covering the deleted scenes
on things you missed whenever they are
released so make sure you're subscribed
to see these worlds from new Horrors
every week bring that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive